[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from heat inist HQ in Williamsburg
Brooklyn where I'm joined by hot ones
hot sauce Somali a noah chamber --g and
today we're cutting straight to the
chase answering one of the most asked
questions in the hot ones mailbox what
kind of hot sauce should i pair with my
food well today we're gonna figure it
all out and first things first what are
you looking for when it comes to pairing
a hot sauce with your meal
well I'm pairing a hot sauce with food
like to consider what are the flavors of
the food where the textures going on
there because hot sauces we know some
are more splashy as they say a little
more vinegary whereas some are denser
and more full-bodied definitely with the
hot ones hot sauce is fiery Chipotle's a
lot more vinegary the dab is you know a
lot denser with pepper so we look at
that look at heat level too what am I
gonna enjoy right now and then we look
at the flavor profile do we want
something sweet don't want a little
smoky with this it's all about finding
the right sauce for the right
application here's something I get
tweeted at me all the time I'm never
always entirely sure how to answer it do
you refrigerate hot sauces the most
important thing for everybody to
remember is you don't want your sauce to
get hot and then cold and then hot and
then cold don't keep it next to the
stove
don't keep it where the Sun is gonna be
shining on it if it's really a vinegary
sauce very stable you don't need to have
it in the fridge something like Tabasco
whereas if it's something that has a lot
of fresh fruit in it that's a little
more prone to spoilage then it's a good
idea to keep that in the fridge and
extend the life
alright enough chitchat Lawrence to the
parents all right we're gonna start
naturally with breakfast eggs staple hot
sauce vehicle Noah what do you put on
your eggs in the morning and why for me
waking up in the morning I like
something with a nice balance of vinegar
flavors and a nice little punchy heat
nothing that's gonna have you a crying
first thing out of bed today what I
picked for us is this smoked onion hot
sauce from butterfly bakery and
this is red jalapenos with smoked onions
so it's gonna have a little bit of smoky
element I'll just go right oh yeah heat
level what are we looking at here
he level here this house is pretty
peppered dense peppers the number one
ingredient so this is gonna be about a 5
out of 10 hmm that's what you want the
onion gives it just a hint of sweetness
perfect to start the day
got some good heat to it it doesn't
matter to it and perfect for this no 5
out of 10 so the number one thing to
remember when it's a dish like our eggs
with yolk like soup something where the
sauce is gonna be totally mixed in is
that once it's in it's in so start with
a little bit make sure that you like it
and then you can always add more from
there you can never add less one dish
one sauce down revolving-door let's
bring in the next one
all right up next we have mac and cheese
and because everyone wants something a
little bit different with mac and cheese
we have options
yeah mac and cheese is a fun one because
you're able to control it a little more
byte by byte personally I'm reaching for
another vinegary sauce because the
richness of the cheese and all the cream
that's going on in there
I like some of that vinegar to be sharp
and cut through so what we have here
today is actually a couple of smoky ones
because I'm really partial to the smoke
but we took it in two different
directions so one here this is a ancho
and mereta from humble house and this is
really like a barbecue e hot sauce it's
two types of smoked peppers with some
tamarind in there so a little sweetness
to heat wise that's gonna be like a 2
out of 10 so that's a nice place to
start and then also from Texas we have
from bravado this is their crimson
special reserve so it's a special
edition of their crimson sauce this one
that's pretty hot the crimson is hot
normally this is the one though made
with the Moruga scorpion peppers so very
hot all right going in with this crimson
so very hot sauce but with mac and
cheese you know because it's creamy
because it's cheesy it's almost like a
built in Kevlar vest for the hot sauce
or something you know it really cuts it
you got a little shock absorber in there
with the dairy yeah it's a really nice
chance to experiment with something a
little hotter than you might otherwise
go really you know it's it's it's a
journey inside you know it's like what
kind of man are you like what's in your
soul like that's really how you can tell
what kind of person you are it's how you
eat your mac and cheese how you pair it
with your hot sauce all right next what
are you going with when it comes to
steak Noah well with steak we have a
really simple protein so we're talking
about one thing so we're looking at a
sauce is a great opportunity to use
sauce with more subtle flavors and
interesting notes the ones that we
pulled out here today we have Queen
Majesty's red habanero black coffee we
also brought out that heatin is number
one I was talking about before from
Dawson's this one has Szechuan
peppercorn so super floral ginger and
lemon and these are all things that
activate different taste buds in
different parts of your mouth so when
you put it on something simple like a
steak you're gonna get that whole
orchestra playing together where you're
gonna feel all these notes separately
little symphony and then this last one's
a little strange I've never seen this
before what what is this this laughs
when we don't let out too often this is
a limited production and yaho pepper
sauce from Nashville yet don't start
with the number one cuz that's gonna be
a little intense this one
yeah thank you for this guy I'm gonna
get this on my plate the nice thing with
the steak is that because we're cutting
it into bites we have the opportunity to
play each bite against the others to
switch it up as we go we're not
committed here you know here we can we
can bounce around
exactly Wow I started off on a hot note
really interesting for anybody doesn't
know Szechuan that's the famous tongue
numbing spice from China just super
floral gives you a whole mouth
excitement this Anejo really took it
over like instead of having a steak I
was eating an Anejo steak same with the
Dawson Szechuan like it immediately
became a Dawson's Szechuan bite of food
when it comes to steak whatever you pair
with it that'll become the star of the
show
absolutely next up we have ice cream and
I'm not sure because it's like I'm hot
ones guy looking at the world through a
different lens these days but it does
seem that now spicy isn't everything
including dessert these days we have
spicy cocktails
we have spicy snacks spicy candy
everything's getting spiced up we
shouldn't forget dessert right and like
I've even seen now increasingly
chocolate bars that are spicy chocolate
and spice are two ingredients that go
really well together and have been used
together for a long time in Molay sauces
from Mexico not all mole aids are gonna
have chocolate but a lot of them that
we're familiar with do so we got another
one here from Brody Dawson this one's
it's chocolate chili sauce and it just
goes perfectly on this vanilla ice cream
and then just like with the mac and
cheese you kind of have you have an
antidote with the kick you know a little
a little ice with the fire yeah mm-hmm
adds a whole nother dimension would
otherwise be just a little bit plain we
have some acidity and sweetness of the
strawberries we have the low notes of
vanilla but the heat just really kicks
everything into high gear turns up the
volume on all these sounds all right
well if you're heard it from Noah you
know that it's gospel now we can knock
you out of your sriracha Tabasco holding
pattern first we feast you already know
heat mist and Noah in the building stay
spicy people
you
[Music]